day long waits in a e
record numbers off work sick
people pulling their own teeth out
seven million on waiting waiting waiting
lists
and ambulances for heart attacks and
stroke victims that don't come on time
just think about that for a second
ambulances that don't come
can any of you imagine losing someone in
that way
I can't I can't and and I mean that in
every sense
I can't imagine it it shouldn't be
possible in our country but it is
a cruel Lottery of who lives and who
dies that the NHS was founded to stop
and until now until this point for 75
years it has
I don't think the NHS survives five more
years of Tory government
people say oh well we've heard this
before the labor party is always saying
it's time to save the NHS
but I say
look squarely in the eyes of the people
who work in the NHS who serve the NHS
and ask them
speak to the working people who use the
NHS who depend on the NHS who need the
NHS
what do they say
and go to the people who believe in the
NHS love the NHS but have been forced to
buy the care they need from the private
sector listen to them
no at the next election the NHS is on
the line the conservative party that's
brought it to its knees will put it in
the ground
but mark my words
if all we do in the labor party is to
place the NHS on a pedestal and leave it
there
that's not good enough either
we've got to fix the fundamentals
renew its purpose make it fit for the
future
to say to the British people vote labor
problem solved would be an insult to
everyone's intelligence
patients can see how deep the problems
go
my Approach is different
it starts with the cause
the central project
how do we serve working people
and then it asks what do we value what
do we conserve cherish and protect
the answer a public and Universal Health
System free at the point of use paid for
by General taxation the NHS
the tourists underestimate the NHS
underestimate the bond between people
and service
underestimate what you can do with a
mission
that yes people go to work in EHS for a
wage of course they do
but of also because they believe in
something
this is how we go beyond the sticking
plaster mindset how we solve the crisis
and tackle the long-term challenges
I want an NHS back on its feet of course
I do
but I also want an NHS that's fit for
the future